first 20 years don't screw it up man
just learn a little bit about life
second 20 years make your money and
really go make your money third 20 years
use that money to invest into your
passions and in the last 20 years go
figure out a way to go contribute back
to society whether it's going to be
charity politics service whatever it is
education but make your money sometimes
when you I chase my passion part-time I
chased retire my dad at a 99 Cent Store
full time I didn't grow up saying I'm
going to go sell life insurance for the
rest of my life I did that because I saw
that as a vehicle to allow my dad to no
longer have to work because he worked at
a 99 cent store for a long time you know
pursue my passion non-stop of course but
sometimes the concept with passion alone
it distracts you from doing things that
we only have to do because we like it
listen a lot of things I've done in my
life I did not like that has allowed me
to do the things I'm doing now that I
love and like a lot